today we're reviewing the nvidia rtx
3070 founders edition card that just hit
the market this has a 500
msrp there are partner models coming out
shortly as well partners of course being
people like
evga aces gigabyte so forth those will
be out in about two days from
the time of this review going up that's
when on videos allowing the release of
partner model cards
and we'll be reviewing those separately
but today we're focusing on the founders
edition card
and testing will include thermals power
frequency overclocking
gaming mechanical assembly so like
pressure testing stuff like that
but we're also going to have a separate
teardown that focuses
just explicitly on taking the card apart
looking at assembly quality ease of
access if you need to repair something
and cooler design from a mechanical
assembly
side of things so check back in a few
hours on this channel for the tear down
video because that'll be going up the
same day as this one
but for this we're going to be focusing
on performance versus 3080 fe for
a point of comparison amd has rdna 2
coming out soon but we can't test that
today obviously because we don't have it
so you'll have to check back during our
dna2 announcements to see
if we have any additional opinions on
this card once that one is
formally announced which is tomorrow at
the time of this going up
before that this video is brought to you
by us and our gamers nexus wireframe
mousemat
aside from being the best way to
directly support our lawn form
investigative reporting
you can also get a custom made high
quality mouse mat made with a high
detail 3d design
that we created to show off heat sinks
coolers video cards and more
the mouse mat uses a stitched blue
border for added longevity
a blue rubber underside for unique flair
and a microfiber cloth for smooth
tracking
the mat is 36 inches by 12 inches and
fits a keyboard and mouse easily to back
order your mouse mat and ensure you get
one in the next run
go to store.gamersnexus.net and
backorder yours while reducing our
reliance on advertisers or
click the link in the description below
it's kind of weird to review
a video card right now at least one like
this where at this point
nvidia is sort of just one upping itself
while
amd is preparing its next gpu launches
that means it's a little bit difficult
to do the usual comparisons because a
lot of the time in the charts we spend a
good deal of
effort analyzing the performance
differences between the closest
competitor from amd
versus nvidia and vice versa in this
scenario though
it's really just nvidia versus 20 series
versus 10 series
nvidia versus the 3080 to see what kind
of performance difference there is there
so it's a little different but uh it's
still worth testing obviously
this card at 500 comes in about 200
cheaper than the floor price of the
3080s
for the most part partner models you
should be attacking on anywhere from 20
to 80 depending on how high end you're
going where
the the highest of the high end mostly
affords you additional
features like overclocking support or
perhaps water cooling water blocks
hybrid cars stuff like that
4k is also going to be a point of
interest here over the years there have
been many cards that were fine for 4k
gaming the 1080 ti was in fact one of
them but
obviously the goal posts move as the
gaming industry evolves and the graphics
options become more complex so 4k
has been kind of a difficult target to
hit for video cards over the years
this one does overall fine with
approaching 4k
gaming as you'll see in our test today
but it's not the first one to have done
it and the 3080 has gotten a lot more
attention
as the true world's first like fully 4k
ready always 4k
playable type of card this however does
threaten that a little bit
let's look at the specs the rtx 3070
runs 5888 cuda cores versus 10496 on the
3090 or 8704 on the 3080.
despite the 3080 being a 47ish percent
increase in cuda cores
there's obviously a lot more to it than
that in terms of determining gaming
performance
we won't see linear scaling and we never
do frequency also comes into play which
we'll show
soon as does memory the biggest change
to the 3070
is that it's moving to gddr6 from g6x
so it's bumping back down to memory
that's easier to cool but also
significantly slower at 16 gigabits per
second stock
versus 19 gigabits per second on the
3080 which also has 10 gigabytes of
memory
as another benefit as a result memory
bandwidth is down to 512 gigabytes per
second on the 3070 from
760 gigabytes per second previously on
the 3080
the bus width has changed from 320 bit
to 256 bit
and another major update aside from the
rt cores is in rops it's going from 88
robs
to 64. now this should be much more
noticeable in
4k than say 1080p test as the resolution
goes up
the 3080 with the rob's benefit memory
bandwidth benefit
should start to pull away from the 3070
at say 4k resolution we've got a block
diagram we can show of the
70 die layout as well and in our tear
down or we can drop in a b-roll clip
here
we've gotten die shots of it where it is
a physically different piece of silicon
the mounting mechanism is actually very
interesting we'll talk about that in the
tear down
but it's a different piece of silicon
it's smaller and so it's still amp here
but it's a cut down version
of amp here anyway we've got a ton of
testing to go through today so let's get
into it we'll open up with something
different that you won't see in the
other 3070 fe reviews just to keep
things fresh
our teardown of this card going live a
few hours after this video
shows just how tightly put together the
3070 fe card really is
there aren't that many screws this time
which is good
but they're evenly spaced with only four
that secure the cooler to the pcb
the remainder of them secure the unibody
shroud to the back plate we initially
had concerns about this
regarding how much pressure is applied
but in this pseudo-color image produced
using a nist traceable pressure sensing
piece of equipment that gn paid for
thanks to its patreon backers and
store.gamersnexus.net supporters
we're able to see just how much that
unibody shroud matters
although it isn't leveraged directly as
a piece of the cooler
but it could be because it's aluminum it
does secure to the back plate in a way
that it's drastically changing the
pressure application to gpu
silicon in this pseudo color image
without the shroud
we can see a major gap in coverage
towards one side of the die
while the unshrouded 3070 fe has the
most even contact we've yet seen
with this new testing equipment this is
basically perfect or very close to it
we'll put some of our previous
measurements on screen as well like the
other founders edition cards and one of
the partner models
as shown here the 3070 fe with the
shroud has even contact
and has good tension across the entire
pcb at least as far as gpu silicon is
concerned
that's off to a good start but pressure
alone doesn't make a good cooler the
pressure map looks good but it isn't a
height map this chart shows the depth
from a known zero point
on a special needle for measuring depth
on things like coolers
more consistent is best so we want to
see a smaller box with measurements
clustered tightly together
the 30-70 feet does fine it's not as
consistent and point-to-point
measurement as the 2080ti strix
or the gigabyte eagle but we also didn't
find any significant
outliers in the measurement that blew
out the scale unlike the gigabyte eagle
the 3070 fe seems fine overall in this
department so
off to the other tests we'll start with
the frequency validation plot
this looks at temperature and frequency
over time which is helpful in
illustrating behavior of gpu boosting
tables
the rtx 3070 founder's edition card
started at about 1965 megahertz
when it was under 60 degrees celsius at
the very beginning of the test
after this it fell slowly to 1890
megahertz to 1920 megahertz went at
steady state thermals of about 72
degrees celsius in this workload
as a reminder this is with full auto
settings so it represents out of the box
usage and out of the box thermals
the v-bios temperature target seems to
be about 72
in this 3dmark frozen frame workload
which is representative of gaming
scenarios
our power virus testing later will plot
higher frequency is relatively stable
but far from the flatline behavior of
water cooled cards
that have eliminated thermals as a
consideration or cards which have
eliminated power from consideration by
way of mods
as expected we're losing about 45
megahertz to temperature as this card
warms up to steady state
this is where board partner models will
often show their value
for perspective this plot will show the
frequency of some other cards that we've
tested recently
we've intentionally zoomed the scale so
that it's easier to read where each one
falls
you'll first see that the 30 70 fe line
plots exactly where it did previously
as the data hasn't changed the scale's
just been zoomed in the rtx 3080 eagle
by gigabyte plots around 2000 megahertz
and this helps us better understand one
of the many aspects
of why the 3080 will outperform the
3070. there's clearly hardware level
differences like
fp32 capabilities memory memory
bandwidth
but frequency also counts for
performance deltas
the 3080fe is much closer to the 3070 fe
at about 1925 to 1950 megahertz the asus
3080 tough cards
also stick around the 2000 megahertz
marker and the rtx 3090
ftw3 runs about 1940 to 1950 megahertz
the highest end nvidia cards like the
3090 typically run slower than the
slim's down counterparts like the 3080s
here
that's the nature of balancing stability
against
more hardware level physical advantages
like more fp32
or other large die gpu benefits time to
move on to thermals we'll start with 40
dba
noise normalized thermals normalizing
for noise helps us understand the
efficiency of a cooler when it's
disallowed from blasting its fan speeds
to compensate for cooler size or design
we haven't tested other 3070s yet
obviously because we're not allowed to
right now
but we can at least show behavior
compared to the other rtx 30 cards
that we've previously tested obviously
these should ideally be power normalized
as well for pure cooler comparison
but since we're comparing across gpu
skus it doesn't really matter
here's the gpu chart for noise
normalized thermals we'll look at memory
next the rtx 3070 fe at 227 watts power
for total board power as validated with
physical interposers
plots at 65 degrees celsius in a 21
degree ambient environment
this is with the card set to 40 dba at a
20 inch distance in a room with a noise
floor of 26 db
that has it about 8 to 9 degrees warmer
than the 3080 tough by asus
which held 56 degrees celsius at 340
watts
without even looking at other rtx 3070
cards this allows us to demonstrate how
partner models can excel
the tough is handling 120 watts more
power
in this power virus workload anyway and
yet manages better results now
of course a smaller die would also mean
less surface area and a higher thermal
density
but the 3070 fe won't be the best cooler
for the rgx 3070 series either
that said it's significantly better than
what we've seen in the past for
reference coolers from nvidia
and nvidia has absolutely improved in
its cooler design
and thermal performance on the fe cards
credit where it's deserved but there's
more ground to gain on partners yet
this chart shows the noise normalized
performance for board components as
tested with thermocouples that we
manually placed all over the board
for the 3070 fe the bottom memory module
measured at 53 degrees on the flip chip
pga side of the silicon
which is well within spec and partially
thanks to the drop from gddr6x
just to gdr6 the top module that we
measured
ran about 60 degrees celsius when noise
normalized but keep in mind that we're
running the fans much faster than auto
here we'll look at that next
the vrm moss measurement ran about 72
degrees celsius
on the i o side of the board which is
getting into warm territory
but still plenty far from the 100c plus
capabilities of the mosfets this chart
shows the same test except with the card
auto controlled
in this one the memory runs at 61
degrees and 69 degrees celsius on the
rtx 3070 fe
with the internal silicon number between
5c and 10c higher than that exterior
measurement that we've taken
that's still fine but it's moving to the
warm end of the scale
the mosfet measurement is more
concerning however at 82 degrees
externally
it's potentially in the low 90s for the
internal silicon
although we can't get the actual mosfet
measurements
because nvidia has decided to not expose
them through software anywhere
we're approaching territory where an
extra 10 degrees internal case ambient
temperature
could mean those vrm components are
running borderline acceptable
at least for long term use this is the
nature of condensing the pcb down as
tiny as nvidia did
coupled with the component choices for
the vrm and with the decision to run
these fans so quietly it's
expounded we think nvidia should
sacrifice some of the noise for an extra
2 dba worth of fan speed
which would alleviate a lot of the
long-term concerns with the cards left
to self-regulate their performance
behaviors the rtx 3070 fe held around 33
dba
making it one of the quietest out-of-box
cards on our rtx 30 benches
when they're all left to self-regulate
it's also among the lowest power
consumption thus far
so this all makes sense the 3070 holds
around 75 degrees celsius when left to
fully control its own fan speeds in this
power virus workload
so vbio seems to have established this
temperature target
and a fan curve that holds around 1480
rpm auto in this benchmark
remember that there are driver level
changes in behavior between things like
firmark and 3dmark
so that's why we'll see some additional
differences in behavior between each
workload
the card runs 5 degrees warmer than the
40dba ftw3 at 400 watts
but because the noise isn't normalized
here you'd have to look
at our previous chart for a real
efficiency comparison this chart shows a
weak point for the 3070 founders edition
it's showing the v bios programming
managed against the gaming workload
applied which is useful for analyzing
hysteresis and responsiveness
interestingly the 3070 fe has a much
more abrupt fan behavior than we've seen
in most other carts
rather than ramping gradually and at a
steady pace the 3070 fe first ramps to
about 1000 rpm
under initial load on a lag by the way
of about 30 seconds from initial load
start
and then it tries to hold this rpm while
load continues to ramp
it holds here for another 40 to 45
seconds and then ramps sharply to 1300
rpm
attempts to hold and then ramps sharply
again to roughly where it rests in the
1480 rpm range
the end result is that the fan's initial
spikes are more noticeable to a human
and therefore more annoying if rather
than attempting to hold that 1000 rpm
first
it had instead continued a gradual ramp
the noise change would have been less
noticeable from a human factor's
perspective
nvidia could improve on its fan
programming for v-bios on the 30-70 fe
namely by changing the lag for ramp this
chart shows the noise levels as plotted
against fan rpm measured with the same
methodology discussed previously
the rtx 3070 fe has a fairly straight
increase in noise with each five percent
increment in pwm signal
the maximum noise level stops at about
56.9 dba at 20 inches
although it'll never reach this without
manual input from the user
software allows this card to be
controlled in one percent increments all
the way down to zero percent
which is mostly unheard of and that's
for good reason because it's broken
that's below what pwm can actually
support and so the card has a hard stop
at 30
and 1000 rpm for actual change although
it can be
technically adjusted in software down to
20 percent one percent
or anywhere between it'll just still
spin at thirty percent speed
normally you see a hard cut off at
thirty percent where software will not
allow you to drag it down
lower uh but this is a mix of software
bugs and things that will be ironed out
later
time to get into the game benchmarks for
the 30-70 as a quick reminder
you can always calculate improvement
against whatever gpu you're using
by looking at the aggregate for old
benchmarks where
you might see the 970 versus the 1070
and say the
later years of the 1070. by doing that
you can look at the delta the average
percentage improvement between whatever
gpu you have and something that
is on these charts by referencing older
data and then you can figure out the
delta between your gpu and what is on
these charts so if yours isn't here
you're still able to calculate where it
should end up falling
we'll start our game benchmarks with red
dead redemption 2 at 1080p
keep in mind that many tests become
somewhat bound at the top end
and don't show as dramatic scaling as
you'd see at 1440 or 4k
in this scenario tested first with dx12
and high-end custom settings
the nvidia rtx 3070 fe stock card ran at
123 fps average
with its oc providing just 3.2 percent
uplift in average fps
and fortunately no loss in the lows
stock to stock the 3070 fe leads the
2080 super by 12.4 percent
with 5700 xt and 2070 super placement
led by 23 the 1080 ti ftw 3
was led by the 30 70 by 37 percent this
definitely isn't just another 1080 ti
in the form of a 30 70. it's actually
improved although maybe nvidia will do
that for the 3060 ti or whatever that's
called
the 3080 fe leads the 3070 fe by 24
at 1080p and that's when both are stuck
let's move on to 1440p we can start by
comparing those previous percentages at
1080p the 3070 fe led the 2080 super by
12.4 percent but now it's leading by 19
the lead over the 1080 ti of tw3 expands
from 37
to 45 percent while the 380 fes lead of
at 1080p stays about the same
maintaining 24
here as well the 30 70 fe plants itself
just under the 2080 ti and just ahead of
the 2080 super oc
compared to the 1070 from a few years
ago the gains are about 128 percent with
one percent and 0.1
lows improving significantly as well
tested at 4k
the 3070 fe still maintains above 60 fps
average with lows reasonably spaced
behind and without any major stutters we
didn't run into any memory limitation
issues here as expected because we're
hitting other limits first
comparing the previous percentages the
380 fe now jumps to 34 percent the head
up from a previous 24 stretching its
legs a bit more with the memory
bandwidth and drops advantages
the 3070 fe holds an 18 lead over the
2080 super
staying about the same distance as in
the 1440p
results the 5700 xt for an amd reference
is led by the 30 70 fe by 34 percent
as is the 2070 super and the 1080 ti
with an overclock they're all about the
same placement
that's up from the 1080p results as well
and so modern changes in memory
subsystems and the architecture have
more notably benefited these higher
resolution tests
again the rops are another notable
contributor here if you're curious about
vulkan performance
this chart shows dx12 versus vulcan
scaling in red dead 2.
this helps to establish how much the api
matters on one generation versus another
we've previously found that vulkan
benefits the rtx 30 series by about 10
percent for the cards out so far
and that mostly persists with the 3070
at 9.2 percent ahead of its dx12 results
some of the baseline performance may
change because of differences in what's
being rendered between the two apis
but the end result is that the 30 series
handles the switch over better than the
10 series cards before it
the 20 series isn't too different in the
2080 super nti class
and the 5700 xt for reference was about
1.4 percent better in vulcan
and so the choice should likely hinge
more on whichever one is the least buggy
at any given time
and that comes down to the game's
developers rainbow six siege is next
we'll start at 4k this time
just because rainbow six siege is so
relatively low in gpu load
that it's more realistically usable the
3070 fe ran
a 144 fps average talk result with lows
at 123 and 118.
that puts it tied with the 2080 ti strix
when stock but allows the strix oc a
lead of 12 percent
our 3070 feoc although stable elsewhere
proved problematic here and posted one
percent worse results than stock
for that reason we've removed the data
from the chart to reduce confusion
we're not able to get a worthwhile oc
dialed in for this game within the
review time window unfortunately
and let's have to try in a few different
settings and combinations
the 3080 beats the 3070 at 179 fps
average or 24 stock the stock the 3070
leads the 1070 by 137
it leads the 1080 ftw by also about
double
and the 1070 ti would be alongside the
1080 here
the 2060 ko is also led by about double
in the frame rate
and improved in frame time consistency
by moving to the 30 70.
the 2070 super is led by just over 40
percent
for averages and that's a significant
generational gain
when considering the pricing and
considering that the super was a refresh
here's a frame time plot to better look
at the frame to frame intervals for each
rendered frame
we're talking a lot about percentages
but that's all calculated against an
average
this is the closest we can get to an
empirical look at gaming
performance for each frame because we
can see each frame's render time
requirement
in the on present metric lower is better
and more consistent is best
in this test the 3070 stock runs about 7
milliseconds frame to frame intervals on
average
and is typically plus or minus one
millisecond from one frame to the next
the largest gap we see is three
milliseconds in general
and as long as the frames don't deviate
or experience an excursion from the mean
of more than eight to twelve
milliseconds
frame to frame at least then no one will
ever notice that difference below eight
milliseconds
especially here we're more talking one
millisecond frame to frame
is not perceptible to a human the 3080
fe stock card ran around
five milliseconds with slightly wider
deviation but also not one that ever be
noticed
at 1440p the rtx 3080's lead over the
3070 is reduced to 19
from 24 as the bandwidth benefit is
reduced here the 3070 stock fe leads the
2080 ti
and the 2080 super oc although to be
fair the 2080 super oc did a lot for
this game just like the 2080 tioc did
it's unfortunate that our 3070 overclock
couldn't hold
as well in this game as others but if we
had more time within the review window
we could have eventually tuned it to
work the improvement over the 1070 is
reduced to 120 percent from 137 percent
again posting higher scaling as
resolution increases and we're not cpu
bound here so it's bandwidth and rops
and architectural changes like fp32
capabilities
it's sort of odd though to review a gpu
in general right now just because
there's no direct competitor from amd
nvidia isn't having any trouble
outmatching its last gen products
so it's almost a little bit more on the
boring side than it might be otherwise
until at least amd gets our dna 2 out at
1080p the 3070 fe manages 385 fps
average so it's showing playable scaling
all the way from 1080 to 4k
the 3080s lead is reduced to 14 while
the 30 70's lead over the 1070 is
reduced to 94
nvidia's investment in bandwidth for
this generation shows it's still a
significant improvement
obviously and if you're unhappy with
your 1070s performance today
it's a big enough job to be worthwhile
that said the price also jaunts an
additional 50
over original msi rp for the 1070
despite being cheaper than last
generation 20 series hardware three
kingdoms at ultra is our most abusive
gpu benchmark you could play this game
at a much wider range of
gpus if you're willing to drop down to
high settings but it helps to have a
benchmark title more brutal towards
cards to fully stress the scaling
at 4k the 39d fe can't even hold 60fps
although obviously a reduction in
settings would make it possible the 3080
holds 47 here with lows just above 30.
that has its average 42 percent ahead of
the 30-70 fe
which is a massive lead when compared to
other tests
that's thanks to the additional strain
produced by these settings
3070 overclock gains us 4.2 percent in
this title
and the 30-70 stock and oc end up
flanked by the 2080ti and 2080 super
the lead over the 1070 is 115 percent
here so it's not further exaggerated
than the previous titles despite the
extra exaggeration at the top end of the
chart the lead over the 5700 xt
on the 3070 is a 45 in this test
we're going to start going faster
through these charts now that there's a
clear pattern formed 1440p is
interesting though for three kingdoms
there's a clear advantage in the 2080ti
3080 and 30 90 and one percent and 0.1
lows interestingly this advantage is
also afforded to the 5700 xt and radeon
7.
although the lows and these aren't
superior to the 3070
they are disproportionately better than
their immediate flanks in the 1080 ti
and 1080.
the 3070 is led by 39 percent in the
380fe
and the 3070 oc improves by 3.9 percent
over stock 3070.
at 1080p the 370fv stock gains by 3.7
to its oc results or 36 percent to the
380 fe that's not much different than
1440p scaling horizon zero dawn at 4k
quality settings had the 370fv at 67 fps
average so it's still plenty capable of
playing 4k
at higher settings you don't need a 3080
for that
and you never did a few years ago we
remarked that the 1080 ti was enough for
many of the times games to play 4k
with moderate settings and in 2018 we
said the same of many of the 20 series
cards
the goal posts move as games advance
clearly but the marketing around the
3080 as the first true 4k
card was always silly and clearly still
is the 3080 leads the 3070 by about 30
percent here
the 30 70 oc gives us an uplift of a
couple percent once again
and the 3070 fe leads the 1080 ti by 36
percent
the 5700 xt by 60 and the 1080 by 79
at 1440p the 3070 fe leads the 2080 ti
strix by a couple fps
but it's led by the 2080 ioc by also a
couple fps
the 3080s lead over the 3070 here is 23
while the 370s lead over the 2070 super
is 37
the same goes for the 1080 ti since
nvidia decided in the 20 series that it
wanted to make a lot more 1080pis
with a different name although we
haven't seen that emerge yet for the 30
series
in shadow of the tomb raider the 30 70
fe at 4k is able to run 66 fps with high
settings
so this maintains that 4k is plenty
accessible on the new 500
card the stack is as follows the 3080
leads the 30-70
at 92 fps versus 66 or about 40
the 30-70 leads the 20 super stock by
9.7 percent
2070 super stock by 23 and 5700 xc by 28
and the 1080 and therefore 1070 ti by 76
percent at 1440p
the stack remains the same in terms of
hierarchy the 3070 fe holds 117 fps
average here so the 2080 ti does keep a
lead in this benchmark
it's still close especially given the
price of the former flagship card
but overall the positioning is roughly
the same as we've seen elsewhere we have
a few other games but they're not worth
talking through as we've already
established the pattern
we'll flash through a few of those
charts here you can pause them if you'd
like any more detail on a specific game
up next will be the rtx games with a mix
of non-dlss and dlss 2.0 coverage for
both angles of the argument
rtx has seen major uplift in the
specific generation as compared to the
20 series
and we explained all the reasons why in
our amp here architecture deep dive if
you'd like to learn more about that
we'll link the architecture piece in the
description below and we'd encourage you
to check it out we'll start with quake 2
rtx this is interesting because it's
entirely path traced using vulcan
and because it's not a hybrid render
approach it ends up exaggerating the
generational rt core improvements as
well
at 4k the 3070 fe clearly struggles and
is functionally equal to the 2080 ti
the 3080 leads by a higher than average
at 1440p the 3070 is in playable
territory at 52 fps average
again tied with the 2080 ti and allowing
the 3080 to hold a 43
lead 1080p posts the same hierarchy the
2080ti and 3070 are about the same
and the 3070 leads the 2080 super by
about 26 percent we use dlss in control
because our user base said that it
prefers dlss in this game
and it's the lss 2.0 so it's better than
the vaseline smear that was offered by
dlss-1
at 4k and with dlss on so not quite true
4k as a reminder
the 3070 runs 47 fps average just behind
the 20 dti
and allowing the 3080 a 37 lead at 65
fps
at 1440p with the lss the 3070 manages
85 fps average positionally the same as
before
and with the 30 80 31 percent ahead we
won't bother running the chart but fps
improves to 118 at 1080p
if you're interested in that minecraft
rtx at 1080p had the rtx 3070 just ahead
of the 2080 ti strix
and the 3080 31 percent ahead of the
3070 but if we switch to 1440p results
the 3070 fe was at 102 fps average ahead
of the 2080 ti strix by about four
percent
power testing is last we're doing this
using a power interposer setup for total
card power
not for system power if you want to
figure out how big of a power supply you
need
you can basically add this number to cpu
review numbers for
a good idea of the worst case scenario
total load
although it's commonly one or the other
component that's loaded for games
obviously then had a buffer after that
for the power supply size
in fermark the 3070 fe card pulled about
227 watts stock
or 247 when overclocked the 3080s for
reference were anywhere from 324 watts
on the fe
to 400 watts on partner models although
we won't plot all of them here
closest proximity power numbers come
from the 1080 ti ftw3
loosely anyway at 283 watts and the 2080
fe at 290 watts
the 2070 pulled about 174 watts in this
test where 200 when overclocked so the
3070 lands between some of these
in total war 3 kingdoms just for a
gaming workload we monitored about 174
watts on the 2070 stock card
200 watts on the 2070 oc 222 on the 3070
and about 321 on the 3080. this is
actually nearly perfectly linear scaling
in this specific test at least the
3080 is gaining about one percent
performance for roughly every one
percent increase in power consumption
it maxes out at around 44 percent more
power for about 42 percent higher
average fps
again in this specific title it won't
always be this clean
but it's cool to see the scaling at
least persist here once you go beyond
the 3080 power numbers though
it all starts to fall apart for power
efficiency versus performance gains so
there is a ceiling to how
long this will linearly scale closing
out then again it's a bit weird to
review
a card like the 3070 right now just
because there's no direct competitor
from andy
the card in a purely objective sense is
good and that it's not
doing anything horrible the drivers
haven't given us any issues
the overclocking was unimpressive
definitely on this fe model at least
and we'll be looking at partner models
later but overclocking is also
so much a function of silicon quality
and unit to unit variants that it's hard
to determine from one sample what it's
going to look like on the whole
but ours was not a very good overclocker
which is unfortunate
because our 3080 fcw3 for example our
first one was one of the best
overclockers we've ever had
but sometimes you get duds that doesn't
mean it'll reflect on all of them
but we do have partner models to look at
so overall we didn't run into anything
experience ruining in terms of value
while
versus the 20 series nvidia certainly
may have painted a pretty good picture
for itself
because it's bringing down its own
pricing for a significantly better or
similar class of hardware depending on
if you're looking at rt performance or
just rasterization performance and
rasterization
it's minimally better overall for
the same price if not better overall for
a lower price depending on which unit
you're looking at
between the skus that are out now for rt
the performance goes up significantly
more if you care about
rtx performance and dxr or maybe you use
something like optics in
blender those are all things that would
be benefited greatly by the ampere
series
and this brings the price floor down now
rdna 2
is right around the corner but andy's uh
update that's coming out tomorrow at
time of this video going live
is going to be an announcement not a
launch as far as we understand now so
there shouldn't be product availability
immediately
but that announcement should at least
give us an initial idea for
when the cards are going to come out at
that point in our amd news piece
we'll talk about if our thoughts on this
have changed at all
or how the rd a2 news has influenced the
the market
the mechanical mount for this cooler is
actually the most impressive we've seen
thus far
in our pressure testing with our scanner
that we use so
that was interesting but gaming
performance overall has you
in the range of 20 to 44 percent higher
than a 3080 it varies
depending on the game and the resolution
at 4k the 3080 pulls away
on average from the 30 70 a little bit
more then i'd say 1080p
and then also in rt performance in fully
path trace scenarios the 3080
does have a little bit more of an
advantage over the 30 70 that becomes a
slightly disproportionate versus
rasterization performance so
1080 ti to a 30 70 to us doesn't
particularly seem maybe worth it unless
you
are unhappy with your 1080 ti
performance now but otherwise that's
still a great card
1070 is about a 2x or greater increase
depending on the game
so that could be a worthwhile change if
you're getting
tired of your 1070 you're not happy with
the performance anymore you want to
increase your monitor resolution
something like that that would be a
worthwhile change 970 holders on
this is actually a pretty good upgrade
opportunity at this point uh although
the pricing has changed from back when
the 970 was launched
so that's it for the review obviously if
you're happy with the video card you
have now
there's no reason you have to upgrade
just because something new came out hold
on to it
make the cards that you have last as
long as you can and
then upgrade when it really truly makes
sense because you're unhappy with the
performance you have uh so subscribe for
more as always you can go to
store.camerasexus.net or
patreon.comgamersnexus helps out
directly
and we'll see you all next time
the